(Hmmmmmmmm)
🤔🤔🤔🤔🤔🤔
(Pewds)
Bet you didn't think I would come from here
The man full of surprises.
What's he gonna do next?
I don't know.
Maybe another LWIAY.
That's right hahaha(laughs)
It's time for
(Beware headphone users)
LWIAYYYYYYYYYYYYYYY!
(Catchy and good LWIAY Intro by Day by Dave)
Welcome, guys. Back to LWIAY
YouTube's favorite shoooow!
Yes, it is.
(Indeed it is)
Stop saying that it's not.
IF I YELL THEN THAT MEANS IT'S TRUE
This👏is👏so👏sad👏
MEME
Is the end of my li- (Oh, I get it, okay)
Cause I, oh (destroy memes)
Good one, NEVER HEARD THAT JOKE BEFORE
*pewds laugh*
You guys are SO CLEVERR
I'm so done with Thanos memes, but I'll read it anyway
*pewds bootyfully reads lowly thanos meme*
WTF only half my squad showed up to my birthday party
*pewds dying inside* Oh yeah lmo i forgot
MY culture is not your goddamn prom dress
I get it
My stepmother doesn't get why I call her 🅱️ONUS M🅾️M
Hahahahahahahhahahahahahahahahahahahahahahaha
*clap clap* (meme review)
👌🅾️👌🅾️🅱️👌👏👌👌🅱️🅱️👌🅱️🅱️
Rockin' The Merch Man, Very Nice.
Bonus Mom! Bonus Mom Can You DRIVE Me Please
Sure Son, I NEVER Wanted I Can Drive You
Veggie Thugs I'm not a vegetarian
Because I Love Animals I Am Vegetarian
Because This Meme Has Been Reposted So MANY TIMES
The Punch Line Has Been Cropped Out, Well Done Guys
And You complain to me about original content
I did not hit her, I did not oh!! hi mark
I cheated on you; it's okay I did
something worse; what? trusted you like if
you cry, can we hit 50 likes if we hit 50
likes then the tears will go away can we
smash it
if this post gets ten thousand of votes
PewDiePie has to release scare PewDiePie
season two well
well Susan Doesn't Know I have episode 123
stored hmm that's right I have them I
have them hostage I will release it if
this video gets 10,000,000 likes that's
all it takes
God is dead love is dead bonus meme is dead
that's right guys I'm sorry to say this
new thing in case you've been away for a
few weeks
bonus meme have died it was stage 5
cancer it came I don't know where no one
thought it would happen
stop crying we need to be strong
that's what bonus meme what it wanted we
need to keep on living as if bonus meme
work with us that's what bonus meme what
a one I know it's hard
I know it's hard but we must go on if
you are- sonic says if you are ever
bored punch an orphan what are they
gonna do tell their parents they don't
have any hooray yeah that makes sense
what's worse then a heartbreak no bonus
meme you just keep having to bring it up
don't you
this dog oh wow what a nice dog Oh on
that day no one noticed that Brad one
actually died why did you think I was
upset you think I just blur out random
words never would never happen out of
touch vice for the love of God don't
meme childish gambino this is America
music video me people who tell me what
to do
vices just lost that it gave his legs
we're gonna do a report about drugs
because drugs are really edgy right you
want to know what drugs the culture one
drugs
we're vice we're really edgy but don't
name childish gambino for the love of
God it has an important message
if you meme it that means if message
just goes over your head to be fair you
need quite higher IQ to understand
Childish gambino so for the love of God
pity pies evolution over the years yeah
say that's pretty accurate hard to
swallow painless oh I thought I killed
this meme because it was a meme review
that's really strange oh look at that
it's the same joke as before
congratulations everyone no you're right
I definitely I'm the one that kills the
memes you're right oh that's cute
pixel animation on Mars and foods in
Japan thank you very much
kawaii desu name I've been just just
killed all the other movies I remember
seeing that post I'm like no way they
came out at the same time that's crazy
good meme how mature artists here tried
painting Gloria Borger ended up looking
like PewDiePie this is really offensive
to me and Gloria Borger please refrain
from doing so
very nice regardless you try let's
pretend I didn't paint this during my
work hours thank you davell neuro yeah
hey look it's the same joke again can
this video get same amout of likes as
dislikes perfectly balanced as all
things should be now a lot of people
seem to be under the impression that we
shouldn't help poor countries because
we're already getting overpopulated
because of them but really what
statistics shows that welfare and
well-being causes people to want to put
reproduce less so by helping people to
live we actually decrease overpopulation
so thinness you're just a big dummy
don't you feel silly now is this Gloria
Borger this took me six hours Wow
I'll tell Edgar wow that looks so nice
why are you wearing this is it cuz you
pee everywhere birth control
effectiveness condoms birth control
pills ass that's right guys have I told
you about ass it's coming out 15th of
May every single console ever yay hurry
if you like ass I think you'll enjoy ass
don't turn your phone upside down just
don't
bonus meme is dead oh my god my mind has
been blown let you at McDonald's in
Norway last week did I see so many
people with white hair and beard okay I
put that on the map but now the new
style the new fashion it's looking like
make huntin on variety of different
video games doing vlogs and real-life
skits doing game
Condon blogs and skits having five
different series just to look at me what
pew news is me discussing memes meme
review is reviewing means look wise
they're all different they're all
different you don't understand silly you
know Apple is run by men when they call
it an iPhone 6 plus and it's only 5.5
inches
of course it's run by men it's a
trillion dollar company not a kitchen
he's right you know
no all right fine breaking news seven
shot at Florida nightclub monster we
found seven new jobs that may interest
seems like dangerous jobs I don't know
if LM interested it was a conspiracy all
along I don't like for tonight not a fan
of Marvel - Marvel Plus epic limited
mashup yeah they're working against me
$8 conspiracy why does all the things I
hate work together against me what's
bonus meme not dying enough must I be
tormented so I drew this so PewDiePie
before they shave his beard it took me
seventy six point three hours I'm really
sorry you spend all this effort but it's
it's really nice I really really
appreciate all the hard work would you
play this a wild meme appears
let the fuck
that's good start your 95 very nice
seems pretty accurate to be honest well
yes yes little eight little taters mom
get fired or something like that that's
for pure loose that's right all the
shows are their friend they were that
would be ridiculous for me to discuss
here white people Asians all look the
same
also white people and there's Cooper's
wolfblade snare broke Baldwin Michelle
Obama they're all very different come on
don't be ridiculous
I'm very proud of my news team working
at Pew News they're working hard and may
I say very handsome thousands of votes
for Gloria Borger to host me review hmm
might be interesting a crossover episode
yes permabanning anyone who calls me
PewDiePie looking sharp there Puetz oh
my god what an absolute sandwich holy
heck dude it's interesting I've everyone
has that style huh hmm my tech cart
cheating on Peas with reporter Gloria
Borger oh my god I don't even know who I
am anymore
Oh
that's so tricks
yeah what religion is this everyone
clapping all the means in the world
times so what are your talents oh my god
this his forehead reminds me of Thanos
chin holy heck dude that's Tanner's
upside down oh my god he's not dead
after all I just want to remind you guys
that this exists good who do you think
it killed pink guy huh why do you think
he just went away build your own robot
lizard oh hi mark
oh okay we're still doing suck memes
okay sorry I didn't realize
lush sucks graffiti Opitz took four days
proven gillian mmm
could this be the greatest art work of
all time sucks thank you very much it's
so cool if you guys know where this is
do you feel free to whom in front of it
to pay your respect and this is America
mean but can you do this
I somehow this meme is still going
strong have I told you about my chair
everybody have I told you guys about yes
answers coming out May 15 check it out
everybody this is like one of the top
most top motive memes of all time
oh look at that it's gone it's out on
Nintendo Gameboy That The Intent Of
Switched A Gameboy Fantastic THANK YOU
Guys For Smashing THAT Like Button
Remember To Submit YOUR MEMES Down Below
That's It For Me For Now I'm Gloria
Borger And
*Outro*